hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his letters to
a young poet Rainer Maria Rilke
addresses the issue of sadness Holly
kite in German and in letter 8 he's
responding to mr. Capas his interlocutor
having told him that he went through a
period of great or significant sadness
and that he's gone through other periods
as well and he's writing to an
interlocutor who clearly has episodes of
he says you know uneasiness or misery or
anxiety or depression and the advice
that he has to give us I think is
incredibly relevant in our own time just
as much as it was in Rilke zone time
particularly since we inhabit a society
which does not equip us well for
understanding and dealing with our own
emotions particularly sadness there's
the same pressure in our own time to
shove it down to conceal it to push it
away to try to forget it to take all
sorts of counterproductive attitudes
towards it that are ultimately Rilke
would say forms of cowardice that shrink
our horizons that cut us off from things
sadness is not always a bad thing as a
matter of fact according to Rilke it can
play it in cred
the important roles a matter of fact it
has an absolutely essential role in our
growth and it can be transformed into
something greater than merely a feeling
so sadness you know if he says it's an
important moment of tension spawn oh and
he describes it this is the way he he
says we feel as paralysis because we no
longer here are astonished emotions
living we are alone with the unfamiliar
presence that has entered us everything
we trust and are used to is for a moment
taken away from us we stand in the midst
of a transition where we cannot remain
standing this actually sounds not only
like sadness and in the sense that we're
used to but also like existential
anxiety as other figures like
Kierkegaard or Heidegger or our Sartre
have described it as well with these
sort of markers of everything being
taken away
Rilke stresses that when sadness occurs
it's not simply because of loss it's not
simply because of frustration or
deprivation it's because something new
has entered into us and we're not quite
sure what to make of it so he says that
there are moments when we we are sad
when something new is entered us
something unknown our feelings grow mute
in shy embarrassment a silence arises
and in the new experience which no one
knows stands in the midst of it all and
says nothing and you can think about the
sadness is that that you feel sometimes
which overcome you they surprise you you
know you could be watching something or
listening to something and suddenly you
feel sad and why is that well something
is happening within you you may not be
able to put your finger on it right away
but he talks about this new presence
within us
he says the presence that has been added
as entered our heart gone into its
internal
chamber and is no longer even there it's
already in our bloodstream it's become
part of ourselves
and we don't know what it was and he
says we have changed there's a beautiful
metaphor like a house that a guest has
entered changes like a house in which a
new presence has come in which alters
the relations between everything else
and Rilke thinks that there's some
mistakes that that people make one of
them he talks about so the only
sadnesses that are actually dangerous
and unhealthy are the ones that we carry
around in public why in order to drown
them out with the noise like diseases
that are treated superficially and
foolishly they withdraw and after a
short interval break out again the more
terribly and gather inside us and our
life life that is unlived rejected lost
life here another beautiful turn of
phrase life that we can die of so there
are way in which our own effective
emotional states can be turned against
us we can't really get rid of sadness by
going out to the bar and having some
drinks with friends not a real sadness
not something that is within us maybe a
superficial feeling blue you can but
going out to the mall and purchasing
something hanging out with your friends
watching endless shows on Netflix
whatever other recourse that you might
have you know hooking up with somebody
and losing yourself in sex the sadness
will always come back if it's there to
begin with it will always reemerge
ladies he says like a disease that has
been treated superficially and foolishly
and then it can become something bad for
us another mistake he talks about he
says that you know one of the things
that that we've we've done and doing a
lot of harm to life is rejecting what is
presenting itself to us he says we must
accept our reality as vastly as we
possibly can
everything even the unprecedented must
be possible within us this is the
courage that's required of us the
courage to face the strangest most
unusual most inexplicable experiences
that can meet us and one of those
experiences for so many of us is sadness
a sadness that we don't understand a
sadness that comes upon us and we're not
sure why it's there we could just simply
reject it or we can take in a different
attitude towards it and so the fact that
people have in this sense been cowardly
has done infinite harm to life they have
ignored or suppressed or pushed away so
many important things that are closely
related to us other people even God he
goes on and he says you know sadness can
make us feel afraid and we can feel a
sense of you know uneasiness with it
that leads to this sort of cowardice as
well
and he tells us we don't really have to
have these terrors as a matter of fact
he's got this wonderful little passage
here he says if we arrange our life in
accordance with the principle that tells
us we must always trust in the difficult
that is to take on the sadness that is
difficult to bear what appears to us is
the most alien will become our most
intimate and trusted experience how can
we forget those ancient myths that stand
at the beginning of all races the myths
about dragons that are at the last
moment transformed into princesses
perhaps all the dragons in our lives
our princesses who are only waiting to
see us act just once with beauty and
courage perhaps everything that
frightens us is in its deepest essence
something helpless that wants our love
and we can understand our sadness in the
same way something helpless that wants
not to be pushed away hidden away
rejected but wants us to take it on and
love it he also cautions against
pathologizing sadness he's talking to
kompis he says you mustn't be frightened
if
Edna's rises in front of you larger than
any you have ever seen if an anxiety
like light and cloud shadows moves over
your hands and over everything you do
you must realize that something is
happening to you life has not forgotten
you it holds you in its hand and will
not let you fall why do you want to shut
out of your life any uneasiness any
misery and in depression you don't know
what these are doing inside of you
why persecute yourself with the question
of where all this is coming from and
where it is going
he says sickness is the means by which
an organism frees itself of something
this is like a sickness you must allow
it to take its course and pay attention
to it rather than trying to drug it up
or find the causes and rip those out and
deal with it in that way now what is
Rilke suggests in place of this taking
on one's own fate one chickasaw in
German the fate that is in fact he says
within you not something imposed on you
from the outside and allowing it its
development its end victim its unfolding
in in the German that he's writing him
here he tells us that this is why it is
so important to be solitary and
attentive to pay attention Alf American
when one is sad why because the
seemingly uneventful and motionless
moment when our future steps into us the
future he says is stepping inside of us
our future is already within us he says
the future steps into us is much closer
to life and that other loud an
accidental point of time when it happens
to us from outside so Rilke is saying
that there's two points in time or
moments or periods of time in which our
future is manifesting itself to us he
says the quieter we are the more deeply
and serenely the new presence can enter
us the more we can make in our own the
more it becomes our fate our shiksa
then later when it happens that it steps
forth out of us to other people it
becomes public we will feel related and
close to it in our innermost being and
that is necessary he says other people
get it wrong they think that fate comes
from the outside but instead it actually
emerges from us he says it's only
because so many people have not absorbed
and transformed their fates that were
living in them that they have not
realized what was emerging from them it
was so alien that in their confusion and
fear they thought it must have entered
them at the very moment they became
aware when it was actually there and he
says the future stands still we move an
infinite space so another possibility
for us is to take on our sadness and
realize that it is a moment where
something has entered into us we pay
attention to it we don't try to change
it into something else
we watch it grow we focus a little bit
upon it but we don't have to spend all
of our time centered upon it and we
don't try to get rid of it because if we
do we're going to miss the opportunity
of transformation that our sadness and
even you know he says depression anxiety
offers to us now this is not to say that
every single sadness should be indulged
or anything like that but we want to be
thoughtful in how we approach our
emotional states we don't want to simply
push away sadness and if you read
between the lines in this what he's
talking about is a way of becoming
familiar with this emotion this
effective state that so many people are
trying to push away or deny or repress
or forget or ignore they're they're not
taking it on with solitude and
attentiveness to use ryoga's own terms
so he's counseling this young man about
something that he could use he's
providing him with a new approach
towards sadness that would allow him not
simply to transform the sadness but
allow the sadness to transform himself
you